the u.s housing market
is booming 5.6 million single-family
homes were sold last year
that's more than at any time since the
2006 housing bubble
according to the national association of
realtors and more and more the buyers
are investors
according to john burns real estate
consulting investors purchasing homes to
rent or flip
currently make up about 20 of all u.s
housing sales
during the pandemic millions of
homeowners have fallen behind on their
mortgages
according to the mortgage bankers
association and rental home investors
are preparing for a potential windfall
some investors are finding homes through
a growing niche known as sale
lease backs that's a transaction where a
property owner
sells a home and then rents it back from
the buyer
are programs like these offering an
opportunity to homeowners
or taking one away
that's where i taught my kids to swim
you know it's just little things
you know my first big major purchase i
ever made my life
i don't really see myself living
anywhere else really wanting to
blane marburger has lived in his home in
denison texas outside of dallas
for nearly 20 years he never expected
he'd now be renting it from a new york
real estate investment company
i kept falling short after the pandemic
ravaged his finances
he found a company through an internet
search that offered to buy his house
for a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars and rent it back to him for 1600
a month
with the opportunity to repurchase it
within a year or two
and eventually this was this was my
option
he raised his three kids here and
imagined he'd stay in the house until he
retired from his job as a physical
therapist
then the pandemic hit he says he lost
half his income as he could no longer
make home health visits
i got a forbearance on the house so i
basically had a year that i didn't make
a payment
during the same period he also went
through a divorce and started paying
child support
i think honestly if the pandemic didn't
come
i could have made it marburger says he
fell deeper into debt and his credit
score plunged
even though he had temporary forbearance
protection which allowed him to skip
payments for up to a year and make them
up later
he worried he could lose the home i was
very apprehensive about doing it
but it was kind of i was coming to the
end of my options deciding what am i
going to do
the company marburger found easy knock
was originally conceived to allow
homeowners to start cashing out their
homes when the market was hot or when an
expense arose
but during the pandemic easynox says it
turned its focus on distressed
homeowners who needed access to quick
cash to pay off debt
last summer it raised 25 million dollars
from venture investors
adding to the hundreds of millions of
debt it had already raised according to
crunch base
in texas alone it's purchased more than
100 homes over the past two years
according to public records we've
grown in the triple digits in percentage
terms over the last year
we've bought north of 220 million
dollars worth of homes
and our average home is pretty much in
line with the national average
which is around 280 thousand dollars
easy knock has a new path to financial
freedom
ceo jared kessler says the company
decided to focus on sale lease backs
to offer homeowners with bad credit a
way to take cash out of their house
all you have to pay is monthly if people
wonder if we're the lost and found and
we're the
destination of last resort the answer is
absolutely not
people can sell their home that's an
easy solution for people if you want to
stay in your home
you want the cash out and you want to be
treated with respect
we're the best choice for marburger
the sale lease back was both a last
resort and a lifeline to pay off his
growing debt
easy knock paid 182 thousand dollars for
marburger's house
which it valued at 315 000
that paid off his mortgage balance of
119 000
including a roughly 58 000 lien from
years earlier
and gave him 30 000 cash to pay off his
debt
easy noc took a seven thousand eight
hundred dollar processing fee and is
collecting sixteen hundred dollars in
monthly rent
in twelve to sixteen months marberger
has the option to buy back the house for
a hundred and eighty seven thousand
dollars
the house was about uh four years away
from being totally paid off
before the pandemic so it's like
i just needed four more years man and
but you know it doesn't always work out
the way that you want it to
millions of americans are in a similar
situation as marburger
about 2.2 million homeowners are
currently in forbearance according to
the new york federal reserve bank
serious mortgage delinquencies those
more than 90 days late have quintupled
since the start of the pandemic
according to mortgage data provider
black knight currently
federal and local pandemic restrictions
on foreclosures are protecting some
homeowners from being kicked out
but ira reingold with the national
association of consumer advocates
is worried about what happens when those
protections run out
he remembers seeing programs like sale
lease backs during the housing crisis
as someone who's done consumer
protection for a long time where people
are harmed the most
is when they're desperate when they're
scared and they're desperate
and they're afraid of losing their home
losing
something right they're afraid of going
into bankruptcy
reingold says he understands why sale
leasebacks are appealing for struggling
homeowners
but he thinks they're giving up too much
for quick cash and he says in his
experience
rarely can distressed homeowners buy
their houses back
i understand the short-term benefit of
peace of mind
the short-term benefit of not worried
about being homeless in a year
but you're giving up your long-term
stability
you're giving up all of the equity that
you may have earned in your home
over these years and if you want
generational wealth if it's something
that you want your kids to have someday
or if it's a place that you want to live
for the next 30 years you're giving all
of that up and you're selling it
really low kessler says that at this
point
about a quarter of easy knock customers
have bought back their homes
morgan stanley analysts say they expect
sale lease backs to continue to grow
because of the robust single family
rental market especially for retirees
looking to tap into their home equity
they estimate there could be a million
homes sold through sale lease backs
in the next five to ten years invitation
homes the country's largest home rental
company
says it is planning a sale lease back
program in the fall as another channel
to add to its 80 000 homes
though it's in very early stages
there's no street lights it's just
holes and you know unless you're really
kind of looking for it you'll
drive by it and not even think twice
at this point marberger says he has no
regrets
if you don't pay rent they're gonna come
take your house it's not a non-profit
organization
they're investors they've got to make
their money too
just like all of us do but he's still
optimistic that he'll be able to buy
back his house
at the end of his 16-month contract i
guess honestly the best way to put it is
i'm still hanging on to a lot of
memories i'm not really ready to give
him up yet i'm not really
start that chapter
you